this week the Senate Intelligence
Committee released a new report on
Russia's attempts to an influence the
2016 presidential election and beyond it
details a sophisticated large-scale
effort using every major social media
platform to sow discord and to suppress
voter turnout in some communities Wired
magazine took a deep dive into the
report and other sources for this week's
story how Russian trolls used mean
warfare to divide America here to detail
the finding is Wired magazine
editor-in-chief Nick Thompson Nick good
morning what am I so great title thank
you vaca t'v but this really isn't new
what it is is uniquely different yes
it's deeper we knew the Russians were
trying to divide America on the Internet
we just did not know all of the details
now we've got an access we've seen the
memes we've seen their strategy and it's
more sophisticated more effective and
worse than we thought you say more
sophisticated how sophisticated was this
one of the differences for me is I
remember when these stories came out and
there was some there you know sort of
eight memes that we saw online I thought
those are kind of lame good well you go
into the full report of all that they
did they actually really understood how
to troll they're really good trolling
memes they're gonna just sometimes I
hate to say it they make you laugh right
what did they do specifically name well
what they were trying to do is they're
trying to get us angry at each other
right trying to get different groups
angry at each other they're very much
pushing Trump from the beginning of the
Republican primaries no up through the
election day they're trying to get
feminists to be less interested in
Hillary and one of the things we saw
they worked on the hardest was
suppressing the black vote and making
sure that black Americans were not
excited about Hillary Clinton and that
was one of the most disturbing things in
places like black lives matter I mean
they were really good at this how did
they get so be good they had an
Instagram account that's basically
trying to suppress the black vote that
has 300,000 followers so they were very
so how did they get so good they read a
lot they research they presumably did
lots of beta tests they put tens of
millions of dollars into this all for
this horrible goal you just mentioned
Instagram we were having this
conversation in the commercial break I'm
more on Twitter Anthony Michelle often
more on Instagram is Instagram more
safe is anything more safe now I know
people have this thought that Oh
instagrams totally good it's right all
the bad stuff happens on Facebook and
Twitter well what happened is when we
all started talking about the bad stuff
happening on Facebook and Twitter
Facebook and Twitter started hunting
down the Russian memes and people
started becoming aware of it so where
did the Russian meme warfare artist go
they all went to Instagram de tormenta
Michelle look at the data on where they
post and where they get reactions it's
more Instagram than anywhere else I'm so
sorry to say is there any way to
calculate what their actual influence on
the elections were no well there may be
if you had a complete data set at the
social media companies if there was a
national effort to share it all but no
and the reports out there say look we're
not saying yeah this swung the election
at Trump and it is also true that the
numbers will they appear high tens of
millions of interactions are lower than
a lot of other things this was not the
primary factor in America's presidential
decision but it is something really
important to look at to study and to do
better with next time could it have been
stopped before yeah I mean if we were
more aware if we'd been watching and if
the social media companies have been
more aware and they've been tracking and
if the government and if the
cybersecurity experts had been tracking
we could have stopped this but then
along those lines I'm thinking it's
almost like a cockroach though like can
you get ahead of it or will it just
continue to grow because if they've gone
to Instagram and they've changed the way
they're doing things can we ever get
ahead of it yes but is anybody in New
York knows and a bunch of cockroaches
and you can handle a bunch of
cockroaches you can't go in a room with
a cockroach infestation so that's what
we can prevent how much did did Facebook
and those companies actually know they
knew nothing until they knew that there
were fishing operations run by the
Russian government during the election
they didn't know anything about the
propaganda campaigns and what we what
these reports are about which are the
meme operations yeah yeah they should
have done scenario planning they should
have done research but we all should
have known like lots of people should
have known all right Nick Thompson
thanks so much for being with us thank
you fascinating stuff